12 frågor där, men jag ska försöka hålla alla i huvudet.
Först tänker jag, vad hade du för plan igen?
Om du inte hade blivit part i det här?
Nej, den håller jag för mig själv faktiskt.
Nej, nej, fan!
Make Sweden Stronger.
Nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kollegor, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag så välkomnar vi Josef Fallesen till podden.
Josef, finns det nog en hel del gamla OG-entreprenörer som har lyssnat på, han var ju med i eller startade upp på business podden ihop med sin kollega Mikael.
Där kan man väl säga att de i princip intervjuade varenda entreprenörer som fanns på den tiden, inklusive politiker och allt annat möjligt löst folk.
Sedan gick han själv in i investeringsvärlden och ja, nu på det allra sista steget får man väl säga att han har startat ett eget företag och blivit entreprenör på riktigt och vi ska få följa med i den här historien och alla lärdomar och allting som han lärt sig under tiden.
Så välkommen till podden, Josef.
Tack så mycket Joel, kul att få vara här.
Ja, du har ju Sveriges gladaste poddröst.
Du låter ju alltid väldigt trevlig.
Är du trevlig som människa?
Jag är...
ja, det skulle jag säga.
Jag har...
jag är den här personen.
Det är svårt att säga nej nu.
Nej, nej men jag är den här personen.
Min festmeddel, det är lite roligt ibland.
Alltså jag är alltid såhär i kassan, ja men tack, ha en trevlig kväll innan dagen.
Jag har fått upp som mamma och pappa att hjälpa folk och liksom komma med energivärde.
Det sitter i min koer, så jag har aldrig hört att jag har poddsveriges gladaste röst, men ja, att uppfattas som en straight shooter, men ändå trevlig, schysst, alltid gå in med öppet sinne, det är liksom viktigt för mig.
Jag kommer bara ihåg när man lyssnade på businesspodd, och detta var ju i poddår räknat jävligt länge sedan, så jag kommer ihåg att vissa av de här pitcharna som spelades in, det var inte högstakvalitet.
Det var tidigt i kocken här jättemycket.
Men du var alltid såhär, ja fan, vi tycker om när ni säljer, vi tycker om när ni är positiva, ja vi tycker om det här.
Du var ju alltid extremt uppmuntrande under den här perioden.
Där måste du tänka också att till skillnad från större produktioner, där pitchar är så, så har man inte andra personer, kontraprogramledarna.
Jag var ju en av två host, jag var producent, jag var liksom VR, så jag var ju de som hade kämpat in många pitchar också.
Det blir ju jävligt skevt, ursäkta språket, om jag såg någon då, som jag har sagt var med i min podd.
Alltså, den dynamiken, det går ju inte att när jag har kämpat och fått in, och det här ska vara ett intressant case där, och här är det lite annat case här, kanske inte lika bra, så jag kan inte ta fram motorsågen själv då för den sitsen.
Jag hade ju alla hattar på mig.
Ja men jag fattar det.
Men ja, just det, hade ni någon, fick Mikael vara lite bad cop, hade ni någon bad cop egentligen, inte riktigt?
Dynamiken var ju, jag var den unga, hungriga entreprenören, och han var ju den äldre, mer rutinerade säljgubben i klass.
Han är ju fortsatt en av Sveriges säljgurus.
Så det var lite, dynamiken vick in på två olika ingångsvärden, på olika generationer, chibchabba lite om det.
Och han var ju inte heller lika nära gästerna och entreprenörer, för det var ju jag som hade kontakten före efter, etc.
Så det var lättare att vara distanserad och liksom så.
Jag var ju mer färgad, jag hade ju mer bias på det sättet.
Var det, jag vet att han är väl din svärfar, Mikael Arntem, men var det du som gjorde allt jobb eller?
Det himla inte han med, han säger det publik också.
Dynamiken i podden, det var magiskt för att Mikael är fantastisk på cell och sådant.
Men jobbet behind the scenes, det har ju han sagt publik också.
Ja, det var majoriteten jag som drog del av.
Det blir inte hans ur om jag säger det här heller, det var så.
Ja, det är gott.
Men ni hade ju med ganska coola gäster, ni hade ju med Stordalen, ni hade med Bärt Karlsson, kommer jag ihåg, ett avsnitt.
Han pratade, det måste ha varit ett avsnitt som inte gick att klippa, eller han bara fortsatte höra för mig och prata.
Han bara malde på liksom, det var rätt roligt att höra på.
Ja, jag var rätt stolt över att jag ändå kunde få Bärt Karlsson att få fokus igen, nu måste vi gå vidare, nu kommer pitchen med två.
Det var inte det lättaste, Bärt Karlsson är Bärt Karlsson.
Ja exakt, ja men ni hade med alla politiker och liknande inför, det var väl val då?
Ja precis, sista året när vi lade ner hösten 2018, då var det ju val, ja det var ju förra val.
Då fick jag för mig att vi borde göra en politikerspecial med de partierna som är närmast näringslivet, jobbet men på båda sidor för att inte ta någon politiskt, vi har ingen politiskt podd.
Så vi hade med Ulf Kristersson, vi hade med Magdalena Andersson, vi hade med Annie Lööf, Centerpartiet, för det var från lite mini opinionsundersökningar, så var det spektrat ändå närmast entreprenörskap, med olika partier på olika sidor.
Men som du säger, ni lade ner 2018 då, men du är ju rätt ung, eller du var ju framförallt rätt ung, och detta är ju ganska hypade människor liksom, och hur nervös var du liksom, och hur kändes det att ändå bli, framförallt i entreprenörsvärlden, rätt känd i den åldern?
Jag blir fortfarande så chockad när man träffade folk, eller smarta, tunga personer, eller liksom jättetunga entreprenörer som gäster, och bara, ja men det ni gör med Bismar, det är grymt.
Josef, du är ju entreprenörskändig, så jag bara, va?
Alltså ordet känd, aldrig, det är fortfarande jättekonstigt tycker jag att säga, eller jag tänker på, vi hade en kul idé, vi ville göra Sverige lite roligare och bättre för entreprenörer med pitchfönster och skapa bra content och insikter.
Så det var drivkraften där och Businesspodden, jag brukar nu efteransse, det var ju min högskola.
Jag har aldrig pluggat på en universitet eller högskola.
Det var liksom min utbildning i entreprenörskap, i företagsmedia och en viss typ av driva bolag.
För jag var ju, visst det var min städbolag, jag var försäljningsansvar och sen gjorde massa saker med det, förutom podden.
Men det var min skola.
Och någonstans, för att knyta till när du sa nervöst, alltså det som var mest surrealistiskt, det var när jag var, var jag 24 då bara eller hade jag blivit 25?
Men när vi sitter med sittande finansminister i finansdepartementet med Magdene Andersson, vi behövde blöra utåt i fönstret som inte så vart det är, det var jätte säpade, vi hade checkat oss innan såklart innan vi fick komma dit och rigga upp.
Men att det var minut-schema, det var i valår, och att få en timme då med sittande regeringsfinansminister för Stefan Löfven, han snackade inte business, han var inte det, men Magdalena Puttrö, hon hade vi alla delar.
Det var ändå rätt surrealistiskt, när jag kom in på klockan, man hade granskats in oss och kom in såhär, hej trevligt.
Det var första gången jag kände såhär, ja men det här osar makt, när det kom in en hel stab runtomkring förberedelser och så bara, det här är sittande finansminister, det är hon som styr budgeten på extremt, alltså det var 1038 eller 1100 miljarder kronor och liksom såhär sitta där och köra med oss två, så bara brid ner föräldrebröskar och bara tycka till och pitcha.
Och just hon fick ju inte, om du lyssnar på det avsnittet, jag tror inte folk har koll på det här, men hon fick inte rösta, annars var det allt att gästen skulle också, vilken tycker du är bäst, anmäla man lägger sin röst.
Hon fick inte göra det för att det är, det är liksom påverkan av, nu minns jag inte exakt den konstitutionella termen, men det är liksom en sittande, igen får inte ta ställning aktivt för ett specifikt företag.
Så då fick vi gå runt också, då fick jag säga så vi inte ställde in det, men du, vi löser, du behöver inte rösta, du sitter bara med och tycker till allmänt, men du behöver inte lägga din röst med jag och Micke.
Så man har blivit lösningsorienterad i businesspodden som blev min plantskola.
Chokade du någon gång eller?
Har ni klippt bort en halvtimme när du bara, fan det där blev inte bra liksom?
Nä men jag tror, vissa gäster som var riktigt tunga entreprenörer, då var man ju väldigt nervös också, men då fick man ju bara hålla masken och sen, ja definitivt att det har blivit uppretningar konstigt, men det är det fina med att vara producenten också.
Det här är faktiskt en kul story.
Jag tänker inte säga vilken gäst, men vid ett fall, det var typ slutet på år två, det är ett poddavsnitt vi gjorde, då det hade hänt en, det var riktigt dåligt med kalendrarna.
Så Micke var aldrig i samma rum som den gästen.
Jag körde ett poddavsnitt med gästen, jag körde med Micke och sen klippte jag och hoppte.
Så de satt aldrig tillsammans.
Men man märkte inte hur jag fick klippa in.
Så ja, man fick bli kreativ.
När vi körde med Fredrik Wikingsson, han hade behövt omboka en gång, sen behövde han egentligen omboka en till gång, men jag hade inget annat avsnitt att släppa, så nu Fredrik, nu får du komma.
Det var liksom när det var valet där med Trump, när Trump i val första gången, dom gjorde en politisk special, men då kodades det Fredrik Wikingsson.
Han ställde upp då, okej Josef, man sätter inte någon i skiten, liksom en gång kan man omboka om.
Så han kom, vi satt en söndagkväll, sen kom han tillbaka med pizza till sina klippare, dom var glada.
Man kom och körde 60 minuter med oss, så kodades det Fredrik Wikingsson liksom där, och jag satt söndag natt och sen gick det ut på måndag morgonen och ingen märkte någonting, och det blev, jag tror fortfarande det var det mest vissnade avsnittet någonsin av businesspodden, för Fredrik Wikingsson, han är king på content alltså.
Fan vad ball, fan roligt.
Det är alltid kul att det finns skit bakom scenerna.
Men jag tänkte på, ni körde på några år och det växte, och ni fick ändå in den skaran, det är ganska nice crowd att bygga ett varumärke på, eller göra någonting på.
Varför lägger ni ner?
Någonstans en viktig drivkraft för mig är growth.
Jag vill lära mig, jag vill bevättra, det ska liksom nästa steg.
Och vi var på vår tid, vi var absolut störst inom vår nisch.
Vi var Sveriges största entreprenörs-
och företagspodd, vi hade liksom ett unikt format med pitcharna och gäster.
Vi hade nått dit vi ville nå i Sverige, och någonstans så kände jag, med media, med poddar, med tv, om det inte blir bättre, jag vet inte varför jag alltid nämner det farmen, men då blir det så här, farmen VIP, då ska man bara ur vattnet.
Så jag vägrade att det skulle bli så.
Så enda alternativ för mig var så här, we're going international, mot USA, jagat, Oprah Winfrey, Jeff Bezos, Bill Gates, alla hotshots.
Och den logistiken, det arbete behind the scenes, det visste jag om man inte hade samma traction i en ny marknad, det skulle vara extremt stort.
Och podden var alltid Mickes nummer två, medan det från år två till år fyra blev min nummer ett i det som prioriterades.
Så rent med kalendrar också, det hade blivit jättestökigt.
Och istället för att jobba med sin svärfarsan, det kan ju vara lite hårfäster på det, så istället för att pusha saker för mycket, nåt nytt och så mycket, det var en perfect timing.
Vi hade bokat in business planar awards, vi skulle ha tusentals persiannexet och köra en stor fest där vi gav ut guldbiljetterna och gav ut pengar till startups.
Det var perfekt att säga att det var vår tacka för oss fest också.
Så jag ringde Micke den sommaren 2018 och sa, jag kommer inte vilja fortsätta med det här på grund av de anledningarna jag sa nu, jag vill gå vidare och hitta på något nytt, för jag hade börjat tänka på andra saker.
Han respekterade det, för det var ju jag som drog mest av det operativa lasset.
Så vi gjorde det till vår avskälsfest på samma gång istället.
Vissa kommer med tåtar till jobbet, vi fyllde anexen med 2000 personer som älskar entreprenörskap och gjorde show av det.
Fan vad balligt.
Jag köper det.
Jag tänkte, sen blev ju du, jag vet inte vad man kallar det när man är den som ser till att investerare investerar, men visst var det det som blev ditt nästa stora uppdrag?
Min nästa uppdrag...
För du hade ju några bolag vid sidan av, men jag tänker det som du gjorde till största procent...
Ja, nej men det...
Jag hade liksom deläger i några sidorsaker som jag ser små...
Men det stora grejen sen var att jag blev partner och Sverige vd för investmentbolaget CG Partners.
Och det är en så sjuk slump, nu när vi sitter och pratar om stories, då kan jag ju berätta det att Christian Geiser, som då blev min chef slash partner, fantastisk entreprenör, alltså en av de sjukaste personerna jag känner och har äran att ha haft som mentor.
Han är typ tio år äldre än mig.
Han har grundat två miljardbolag, investerat nu är det väl typ 60 plus startups.
Han är tysk.
Om i en slump så råkar det vara så att han har en svensk, på då tiden flickvän som blev hans nu fru och mamma till hans barn.
Så han har liksom haft en naturlig dragning till Sverige, men han känner typ inget här.
Så redan några tidigare när jag jobbade krog, för en gång i tiden så jobbade jag bordschef inom Autofoffice och inom Sturplansgruppen på en av de coola klubbarna.
Då kom han som gäst av en slump och han var så otroligt nöjd med min service och lite simpla saker man kan göra för att göra lite extra.
Så han blev en av mina bästa gäster.
Och jag visste inte vilken hot shot han var från Berlin, men när jag satte igång business podden så berättade jag det till allt och alla, I have a new podcast, we interview entrepreneurs pitching, like shark tank dragons, it sounds interesting.
Och där tänkte han, fan jag borde nog börja hålla koll på den här unga hungriga killen.
Det kan nog bli någonting.
Så från att han var typ en av mina bästa gäster när jag var 20-21 till att jag några av senare business podde blivit väldigt stor och tänkte vi ska nog testa att göra ett engelskt avsnitt.
Vem känner jag för att doppa tån där mitt första...
Christian vet du jag har sett han med Angela Merkel på coola summits.
Jag har sett han front row seat med Mark Zuckerberg.
Jag ser att han ibland i USA gör tech...
Han är nog en hotshot så bara helvete fan.
Hans bolag går jättebra, han är ju jättestor.
Så då frågar jag kan du gästa podden?
Han gästade podden ett av de sista avsnittet 2017.
Sen insåg han att jag hade ju byggt upp ett nätverk, ett deflow, kontakter inom pitchande startups.
Det var ju det som ledde till att jag fick jobbet som investerare för han var på finalen.
Han hade inte fattat att vi skulle lägga ner.
Så han frågade sig någon annan.
What is he saying?
Is he quitting business podden?
Why?
Business podden is great, it's a huge success.
Så han ringde mig dagen efter.
Han bara, Josef, du är smart.
Du skulle aldrig lägga ner det här om du inte 100% hade något annat på gång.
Skit i det där.
Skit i andra planerna.
Bli min högre hand istället.
Du har ju sagt det till mig att du vill hålla på med investeringar, med draknäst, ett massa sådana saker.
Bli min kompagnon.
Jag kommer att lära dig.
Vi investerar mina pengar och du får en bra setup och en bra outplay.
Det var det som hände att jag fick ansvara för att upp till cirka 100 miljoner kronor.
Inte någon fond, det var Christians pengar.
Jag brukar säga att vi var ett family office fast vi inte var family.
Att det skulle investeras i...
På tyska sidan hade han sin andra partner, min partner i Fabian och i Sverige mig.
Det var så jag blev investerad.
Stjärnorna var aligned, man hade gjort rätt saker flera år och min långsiktiga plan har alltid varit att skapa och vara en del av en form av ett Shark Tank-draknäste.
För när jag var 17 så blev jag golvad av det programmet när det hade premiär Shark Tank och Draknäste UK lite innan och jag älskade det formatet så jag bara, jag ska hålla på med sånt där, jag ska bli entreprenör, jag ska pitcha, jag ska skapa något sånt här format så det har varit min ledstjärna och det var så jag kom in och blev partner på CD Partners som jag sen jobbade med i två år.
Tolv frågor där men jag ska hålla alla i huvudet.
Men först tänker jag, vad hade du för plan igen om du inte hade blivit partner där?
Nej, den håller jag för mig själv faktiskt.
Nej, nej, fan!
Helvete, vi ville ju se vad du egentligen hade gjort då.
Det hade varit skitkul att veta.
Okej då, nej, fair enough, jag ska inte rota.
Okej, ja, vad var första när du...
Hur snabbt gick det att komma in?
Det låter ju som att han var en decisive person, så jag gissar att du satte igång där ganska fort.
Det tog inte lång tid att komma igång.
Jaja, och grejen var att det fick ju bli crash course direkt i vad vi skulle titta på.
Vi investerade ju väldigt, alltså pre-seed och seed.
Så i början var det ju bara riva upp mycket damm, få bra benchmark med vad vi tittade på.
Och sen var det ju han som tog, till syvende och sist var det hans medie, han tog ju alla beslut men med tiden så blev jag mer säker, och kunde argumentera och ja, kommer gå in med några av mina egna pengar fast jag inte hade alls på närvid så mycket pengar som Christian.
Men det fick ju bli crash course direkt i i vad heter det, att leta investeringar.
Och nu, hindsight, man är ju allt efter klok.
Hade jag liksom varit hans partner på City Partners nu, med allt det av att driva ett riktigt techbolag från grunden och göra det vi har gjort nu.
Alltså, off vad mycket smartare jag hade varit där i den sitsen.
Men man lär sig allt efterhand alltså.
Det är en annan tid också.
Även om det låter som att det inte är så länge sen, så är det ju, alltså fem år i den här världen är ju många år.
Ja men det var ju en galen tid 2018 till början av 2021.
Det var ju crazy times.
Men kan du inte berätta lite vad känslan här första, jag tror att det finns antagligen ganska många människor som är entreprenörer och som ändå drömmer om att det hade varit kul att sitta på andra sidan stolen eller att få göra den grejen som du ändå gjorde där.
Kan du inte bara beskriva känslan av de här första mötena?
Hur tänkte du när du gick in i rummet?
Hur tänkte du när du besmötte entreprenörerna?
Vad var det du letade efter eller var du bara helt blank och tänkte fan vad ska jag göra?
Jag får fråga någon bra fråga här.
Nej, nej jag var inte blank.
Jag hade ju liksom live varit minidrak i fyra år med businesspodden.
Jag hade ju liksom, de som fick guldbiljetter, de vi tyckte var bra, så hade vi ju skickat vidare till våra affärsingepartner.
Det var redan en liten del där.
Det var ju kratta till vad som skulle gå.
Nej, så jag var ju verkligen inte grön.
Men jag var ju inte liksom såhär, hade pluggat x antal på McKinsey eller jobbat där.
Gått från Handelshögskogsmaffian om man säger så, utan det var ju mer lärande på en egen sätt.
Men det vi letade efter, det är ju klassikern teamet.
Vilka är teamet?
Det är ju grunderna.
Allting, det är ju en så otroligt hatad älskad flosker, men det är ju grunderna det hänger på.
Det vet ju du, det är en bistid.
Man pivotar ju tre eller 208 gånger i min eller stora pivots.
Så det är ju rätt grunder med rätt bakgrund.
Och sen var ju, vad är marknaden?
Hur stor är marknaden?
För det är vissa som inte har varit i investeringsvärlden, för du tänker på att alla ska ju inte ta in externt kapital.
Vissa branscher ska inte bli externt finansierade.
Speciellt inte av VCs, kanske av änglar som vi var med i.
Ja men, där kan man ju mer diskutera.
Änglar älskar jag fortfarande, det är fantastiskt.
Men alla branscher, hur stor är marknaden?
Finns det potential så att det finns pengar och tjänar som investerare?
Och det tredje, det är ju produkten.
Hur löser de det?
Har de någon form av unik twist, eller finns det någon produkt, eller finns det någon tanke som kan flyga?
Det är ju de tre penar man alltid letar efter.
Team, marknad, produkt.
Och problemet var, jag och Christian pratade ofta om det.
Det är hemskt att man ska hitta rätt.
Det var ett jättefantastiskt team, med kanske fel marknad eller produkt.
Eller så var det ett jätteintressant marknadsprodukt.
Men helt fel team.
Det var liksom bara, kan man byta här och göra så?
Det är ju svårt med investeringar.
Att göra investeringar är ju enkelt.
Att göra rätt investeringar som faktiskt tjänar pengar på eller krasst inte förlorar pengar på, det är ju mycket svårare.
Men går man alltid in som investerare och letar efter en full house, man vill ha alla de där, eller går ni ibland in för att gilla teamet så mycket och försöker sälja in dem på, vi går in om ni byter, förstår du vad jag menar?
Ja, en av de investeringar vi gjorde som sedan, det blev okej, vi torskar inte pengar men det blir ju inte en jättefansig grej, det var Kling som såldes till Fort Knox, ett offert avtalssystem.
Där såg vi att grundteamet, jätteintressant, det fanns potential, produkten var fantastiskt i nisch, men det fanns en stor marknad att bredda scope och springa efter.
Så där var det lite bättre att springa efter här och göra det på rätt sätt.
Nej, vi var inte låsta, det kan man inte vara, allting förändras, så man måste våga vara riskbenägen, det heter ju riskkapital av en anledning.
Jag hade med Pelle Pettersson, han heter väl Pettersson, jag får skitförrättar, men Pelle på Omniarts i alla fall.
Han sa att när de letar rekryteringar, så letar de efter folk som kan ge konkreta svar.
Jag tyckte det var en jävligt, fan vilket bra svar typ.
Hade ni någon sån där grej som ni letade efter för att se att det här är rätt människor, fanns det någon enkel grej?
Kul att du säger konkreta svar.
Det tog jag med mig av Christian också.
Men det var verkligen, han störde sig som fan på när det inte var raka svar.
Man får svära i denna podden, jag svär mer.
Nej men just när det var för mycket, det var ett konstant ord, too high level perspective, too high level answers.
Det behöver inte vara rätt svar, men ge ett konkret tydligt svar.
Christian har ju äskat jättemycket pengar av tunga investeringar, han har gjort det real deal och byggt upp i hundratals anställde, flera marknader.
Han vet att folk, attention span, hur man säljer, det måste vara jättekonkret.
Så om man snörar in sig, det behöver inte vara det bästa svaret, men det måste låta säkert och det måste finnas data som backar upp det.
Det var något som jag älskade med att jobba på daglig basis med Christian.
Tyskar, de är rätt speciella, de är ju straight tutors, men han hade ingen pride alls i att ha fel.
Vi kunde sitta och argumentera om saker, jag tycker du har fel nu Christian.
Jag har rätt men okej, let me hear.
Och sen kunde jag komma med data på det här, det här, det här.
Och så kunde han göra en 180-sväng i sittande möte, bara för såhär, I hear you.
Okej, okej, sounds reasonable.
Ingen pride alls med såhär, nej det här.
Ingen sankost utan bara, datan finns här, argumentationen, let's go, okej kör.
Alltså fantastiskt leda stil är, bäste idé, bäste argumentation uppbyggd med data vinner.
Och det, för att svara på frågan igen, men nu fick du en story på det.
Ja, samma sak gällde för Christian.
Inte för high-level-svar, utan det ska vara genomtänkt i detalj.
Sen behöver vi inte tanke på det som blir rätt, men det måste finnas ett strategiskt tänkande.
Exakt, det är inte bara en floskel som du har hört, utan du har i alla fall gjort en tankeprocess bakom, och kan presentera det.
Det som när min flickvän är lärare och hon säger att man får ofta en poäng för uträkningen, även om svaret inte blir rätt.
Ja, fair enough.
Jag visste i skolan också när man gav rätt svar men man kunde inte förklara det så detaljundteligt.
Varför fick jag bara så här poäng här?
Då har jag inte visat hur jag har tänkt.
Du kan ha fuskat, nej.
Vad måste jag förklara hur jag har kommit fram till?
Ja Josef, om jag ska MVG så behöver jag, för jag var ju så här klassisk, mellan VG och MVG person.
Ja, jag var likadan.
Ja exakt.
Charme är man lyckats sköna till sig bland MVG person.
Ja, men sen var du där ett par år och sen slutade du med det.
Och jag har för mig att jag har hört dig i någon podd säga att, inte att du var kanske skälad dödande, jag har för mig att du använde det ordet.
Att det var så här, om man bara investerar och säger nej till folk så är det lite typ lässant eller liknande.
Hur kommer du ihåg det?
Är man entreprenör så finns det inget fel tanke, speciellt för mig med business-planbakgrunden och draknas det så att vilken extremt kul grej att få ge tillbaka som investerare och ge pengar.
Problemet är, och jag står fast vid det jag har sagt, att det är på ett sätt skälad dödande.
För att du letar ju fel.
Du letar ju med dig, vad kan gå fel här?
Så ens jobb blir ju, om man vill vara så att man vill det inte, att försöka skjuta saker i sank.
Och if they still standing, the case.
Då blir det, men det är ju det som är.
För någon som är en säljare i grund och botten, och småföretagare och entreprenörer i grund och botten, liksom som är van att vara optimist och tackla tillbaka det omöjliga, motbevisa allt och alla bara för nu kör vi och bara pusha igenom.
Det är, jag står fast vid det.
Jag tyckte med tiden att det är att leta fel och säga nej tack, nej tack på grund av rimliga anledningar.
Det är lite stjärladödande.
Det var inte för mig att vara det full time.
Och jag tror att många entreprenörer som också änger investerar eller vart det, förmodligen kan backa upp det också så att göra det på heltid, det är inte något för de flesta entreprenörer.
Då är man inte en riktig entreprenör, utan då är man ju mer tjänsteperson, vc.
Men att vara full bussentreprenör, då är affärsängelskapet fantastiskt men inte kanske på heltid.
Jag fattar, vad spännande.
Finns det en vanlig anledning till att man säger nej till folk, eller är det bara väldigt olika beroende från case to case, eller är det ofta standardgrejer?
Nej, det är helt olika på case to case.
Eller är det att företaget är icke-investerbart, eller är det bara att det finns väldigt många dåliga företag?
Alltså jag är inte den bästa affärsängeln att fråga om vc sånt här, så det borde du göra någon specifik podd med andra som du kommer få mer ännu bättre data.
Fy fan du kan bättre än mig.
Ja men det ska jag inte, förmodligen eftersom jag har ändå professionellt jobbat med det i ett antal år och allt det andra.
Men nej, jag skulle säga, det finns ju klassikerna som aldrig kan säga nej till case om det är liksom alldeles för lite traction med ett team som inte har gjort någon form av exit eller jättehög trovärdighet för och frågar om astronomiska summor och värderingar.
Det är ju bara såhär, det kan ju gå bort direkt då.
Det här finns ju inte alls mycket i verktygetsrankning.
Och sen pratar ju folk om hur kan den här personen X få sätta värdering på 200 miljoner vid ritbordskits när de pitchar in och tar in 40 miljoner kapital.
Jo, för att de som gör det är förmodligen second time founder.
De har förmodligen gjort affärer med den vc, investingen eller någon annan och tjänat pengar att de förr, så risken är jättemycket mindre if you are a second time founder.
Men det skulle jag säga är en klassisk att det finns inte så mycket tyngd sen tidigare i teamet och det är frågor som alldeles för höga värderingar.
Så astronomiskt då är det såhär, ni måste komma ner men vi är förmodligen långt ifrån varandra så ja, då blir det inget.
Sen, du jobbade med detta i två år ish.
Men vid sidan av så drev du, hade du kvar, visst hade du Workout Parties var ett bolag som jag vet, och du hade någon städfirma vid sidan av också.
Nej, Workout Parties var parallellt med Businesspodden, men det var jag och Infestment som drev det tillsammans.
Jag har jobbat klubbtider med Bordschef och Sturplandsgruppen, jag slutade dricka alkohol för nio år sedan.
Det kändes fel i min core, för att sälja en produkt jag inte själv tror på längre.
Men jag älskar eventformat, jag tycker det är extremt kul att smälla konfetter, det är bra stämning med folk.
Så då kom jag på Workout Parties, ta bort alkoholen, DJ, alkoholfis, skumpa, protein, drinkar i baren.
Vissa tyckte att det var värst där de hört, spymorg, andra tyckte att det var åh helvete, bäst det jag någonsin varit på eller sett.
Men det kördes 2015-2017 på här med Businesspodden, men vi valde att liksom lägga det på isvilande, bara för att Businesspodden började gå så jättebra, jag behövde ha fokus.
Men nej, det gjorde jag inte som investerare och städbolaget.
Men så när du stängde ner som investerare, då var det liksom nytt på riktigt, då skulle du hitta någonting som du skulle viga ditt liv åt.
Var det så det var?
Nej, planen med övergången från investerare till vem, det var inte så dramatiskt som man kan tänka utifrån, utan det var att en del av CJ Partners affärsidé hade börjat bli under 2019, andra halvan, att vi skulle co-founda bolag.
Att vi som investerare skulle hitta, skulle vara founding investor och hitta hål i marknaden, pinpointa personer som kände varandra innan eller skulle kunna vara ett bra team och gå in med första plåten pengar, för det liksom finns någon form av trund där.
Så det var bakgrund till att, och det var något jag tyckte var mycket roligare på slutet också, att hitta, ja men vi satt och det här caset, och vilka kan vi matcha här, investerar då på det sättet.
Och jag minns att jag kommer aldrig att glömma den lunchen där när Christian var i Sverige, och det var innan corona hade brytit ut, men det var liksom där, slutet av 2019 började 2020, och han sa det till mig, Josef, det var ju då, du trivs inte 100% som investerare va, fulltime.
Så jag ba, nej.
Jag ba, men jag har märkt det, du är ju som mig.
Jag själv kan, det är därför jag har dig och Fabien, det är därför jag själv nu startar mitt nya.
För jag vill inte jobba med det här fulltime, caset är jättekul, ingen investerare men inte fulltime.
Så han sa, nu gör vi såhär, att du ska bli vd och grundan är ett av bolagens co-foundar tillsammans med dig och någon mer då.
Så gör såhär nu, kommande tid, parallellt med det vanliga.
Gå och se hål i marknaden, vad du är bra på, vad du stör dig på.
Och sen när tiden är redo och du har något, då pitchar jag här för mig och Fabien och if it still stands, då kör vi.
Så det var övergången hur det började gå mindre och mindre investering och mer vad ska göra sen och sen VAM och ja, sen har det varit det sen dess.
Jag tänker jag älskar det här med att man ska co-fanda företag.
Jag kan tänka mig att det är väldigt roligt liksom, men är det en bra affärsidé tror du?
För vem?
För investeraren.
Det måste vara ganska lätt att, jag vet inte, att du startar bolag som inte blir bra.
Nej, det ska jag inte.
Om jag tittar på de bolagen som har springit ut, Vem är still standing och går aldrig så bra som det går nu i Sverige?
Och om jag tittar i Tyskland, de andra bolagen som har skjutits ut nu, senast, det är väl sex bolag totalt nu under fyra år?
Alltså vissa är snart miljardboll, de är ju hundratals.
Det är riktigt bra bolag, men då får du tänka att Christian är världsklass, han har ett sinne för affär, entreprenörskap, Fabian som var tyska partnern, var hans högre hand i hans stora koncern som han byggde upp tidigare, så de har jobbat för en nära länge.
De känner jättemycket rätt entreprenörer som vill hitta på något, då kommer tryggheten in och bara tar klivet.
Så nej, gör man det rätt, och inte gör det som fabriker, utan pinpointar ett nytt case per år, och utöver investering man gör med ett nytt på att ska co-foundas, då kan det bli riktigt bra.
Och sen som investerare, för det måste rimma med om man ska titta mer kapital, så man kan inte ta mer än 10-15-20% för första plåten och co-founder.
Men det kan bli värt väldigt mycket när det blir riktigt fina bolag.
Jag tilltalas av den tanken väldigt mycket.
Jag kan tycka att det är fint med det.
Det har varit kul att se lite data på det, för det känns läskigt att man ska chansa på folk innan de har visat nån traction.
Jag fattar att du menar att det kanske är second time founders och allt sånt där, men jag bara menar att det är läskigt med företag som inte visar traction.
Och där är det ju mycket.
Om du har en stor plånbok själv, då är ju inte 100 000 euro, 200 000, det är inte lika kännbart kontra en vanlig döddis som mig.
Det hände ju inte där.
Men om man har en större plånbok och brinner för start-up som Christian gör, då var det ett naturligt steg.
Sen tänker jag att vi har två simultana historier här.
Dels kan man ju säga att du är med i draknästet på riktigt nu, och dels kör du vän då.
Jag tänker att vi sidospårar det här lite med draknästet, för det känns som en kortare story.
Så tar vi vän på slutet.
Vad är din roll där?
Min roll i draknästet är, min officiella titel är att jag är redaktör och castare.
Det betyder att jag jobbar precis sida vid sida med producenten.
Jag ansvarar för att innehållet, det är jag, Karin O'Connor, Karin är fantastisk, det är vi som är näringslivets representanter i redaktionen så är det inte bara mediatv-människor utan att det faktiskt har örat mot rälsen.
Så min roll där är att se till att det är rätt mix av entreprenörer, kul case, bra case mix, men framförallt som det har växt med tiden, för Karin har mer gott närkontakt med entreprenörerna och jag har mer med drakarna, att det är en mix av drakar som är upp-to-date med hur Sverige och investeringssverige ser ut idag.
En bra mix så det blir både tv och seriöst.
Så jag brukar säga att när fram tills folket är i studion, så är jag en av de absolut mest ytterst ansvariga.
Det är liksom mitt huvud som kan rulla då, om man säger så.
Men när väl folket är i studion och det är en bra mix, då sitter jag där och kulissar och njuter och tittar.
Som liksom, först är tittare, om man säger så, och sen efter inför det kan jag ju vara med med PR och liksom göra sådant.
Men det är min roll där, att se till att vara med så att att producera det utan att rent tv-mässigt producera, men liksom producera själva innehållet med drakar och entreprenörer.
Men du sa att du hade mest hand om drakarna, om jag förstår rätt då.
Med tiden har det blivit så för att jag fick för mig för några år sedan, att vi borde ha gästdrakar i Sverige.
Vi borde liksom göra, i Shark Tank tar de in ibland, typ Kevin Hart kommer in där, så kommer hon som gör ett spänk, alltså jättetunga entreprenörer som kommer in, gäst som inte sitter där med de fasta.
Så jag hade fått för mig att det skulle bli ett kul inslag för tittarna, dynamiken etc.
Det gillade kollegerna i produktionen och kanalen SVT.
Så då var det bara löst, ja löst det.
Att lösa en eller två, från början var det fem men sen två nya drakar, det är ganska mycket enklare än att lösa sju drakar.
För då ska gästerna in i kalendrar.
Så då helt plötsligt så, då blev det ju mer att, Josef du är grym på det redaktionella och casten med drakarna.
Drakarna är ju de största namnen, du måste ha full fokus där.
Du hjälper till med entreprenören och drycker in några spännande, mer mot andra halvan av den delen.
Men nej det var drakarna, ja det är drakarna som varit på mitt bord.
Castas drakarna liksom, finns det en väntelista kanske du inte får säga, men finns det en väntelista på drakar eller folk som vill vara med, men det är såhär, nä du är rätt tråkig.
Eller är det snarare så att du outreachar och bara men vad heter han, Fredrik Eklund, han, visst är det han, ja men han är ju en extrovert människa.
Han är ju en extrovert människa, det blir ju bra TV liksom, han är ju rolig.
Det är ju lättare att casta drakar som det finns mycket rörligt material på redan, i affärskontext.
Det är ju lättare att för mig själv bygga en uppfattning och även för alla andra stakeholders som ska känna att det här är bra, det rimmar.
Så ja, självklart pågår det ju liksom castingprocesser med väldigt många simultana personer och dialoger.
Men mer än så kan ju inte jag tyvärr uttala mig.
Nej, helvete.
Ja, det är många nedstängningar i den här podden.
Vi hoppar.
Många, vilka mer är det?
Du stängde ner mig vid ett tidigare tillfälle, jag kommer inte ihåg vad det var.
Jo, det var vad du skulle ha gjort istället för att bli investerare.
Ja, ja men...
Två då?
Det är...
exakt, ja.
Två, det är nog...
Det är okej.
Och om vi simulterar med Draknäste exakt med Vem, det var ju det att jag hade slutat som investerare.
Jag hade kort efter, jag hade precis startat Vem och vi började springa där.
Och nu är det liksom, eyes on the prize, bara Vem, nu kör vi.
Men så fick jag det där maillet, alltså det där maillet som man inte tror är det sant.
Det är liksom någon form av blott men jag kollade ju upp allt, stämde ju.
Det var från första producenten då, Ulrika Bidning, fantastisk kvinna.
Hej Josef, jag lyssnar på business podden.
Jag har sett, du är ju investerare nu och du gör medier bra som investerare också nu och jag läste något om det, väm, det låter ju jättespännande.
Jag vet inte om det här är intressant, blablabla, men vi måste ses.
Draknästet kommer äntligen tillbaks till Sverige och jag kan inte tänka mig någon annan bättre person än att prata.
Jag vet inte vad din roll ska vara, jag vet inte, drake, hjälp, någonting.
Det var ganska blankt, men de bara, vi måste ses.
Det var ju Lidit, det var ju Ulrika på ITV, så jag bara, okej, jag får ju ta en snack i alla fall.
Och då var det ju uppvaktningslunch där, det var producent, projektledare, innehållschefen i Sverige och vdn på ITV i Sverige satt där.
Så jag kom ju förberedd också, man måste alltid vara förberedd när man får chanser.
Så jag visste exakt vilka, jag hade ju tio eller tolv drakar, de här drakarna borde vi ha.
Hur tänker du, ska vi ha som förut med en programledare?
Nej, nej, nej, det ska vara shark, man kastar sin handledning direkt, ingen programledare direkt in så.
Så där och då, i sittan med att det sattes mycket snabba beslut kring hur ett modernt raktnäste, vi pratade om det då, sen bestämdes det korta efter, men det var starten och sen efter så återkopplade jag, tack för senast, vi måste jobba med dig Josef.
Du måste vara en del av produktionen, snälla, kan du tänka dig bli redaktör?
Jag sa då att jag driver VAM, det är mitt åtag nu, men det här är ett så kul hjärteprojekt, mina investerare, dracknästet är en cool grej, men att ha en hobby, även om man investerar, det är okej.
Nu råkar fallet vara att min hobby är startups och pitchande.
Då kunde jag komma runt det med, jag har ett litet sidoprojekt som kommer att ta under Q1, för det var typ december och januari, februari, och under Q1 kommer det att vara extra mycket arbetsbörda, extra mycket timmar då, men det är liksom inte så länge, och det är liksom en riktigt viktig och kul sak.
Och sen var ju karusellen igång.
Fan vad kul.
Tänk om den lille Josef hade sett det, det hade varit skitroligt.
Det är en sådan där cirkensluten.
Nej, cirken är inte riktigt slut än.
Den lilla Josef cirkenslut när jag sitter i en av stolarna.
Okej, det är klart.
Det är väl ändå rimligt, det är du som kastar om några år här.
Jag vet ju själv vad vi letar efter, så det är liksom två saker, två saker bort.
Det finns delvis storyn, det måste bara bli lite mer pengar, affärsmässigt tyngd och sen lite mer pengar och sen why not om man säger så.
Men jag har ju aldrig haft en så podd position för det som det har.
17 år, 18 år, Josef som jag delvis jobbar för.
Jag skulle vara stolt över mig själv.
Ja det tycker jag.
Vad roligt.
Nu ska vi komma in på Vem också, så att vi inte spårar in på allt såhär roligt sidogrejs på vägen.
Men det är ditt, inte nya nu kanske, du har hållit på ett par år, men ditt senaste bolag då.
Kan du inte berätta lite vad ni gör?
Vem är ett säljverktyg som hjälper B2B-företag att få fler varma leads?
Det gör vi genom att automatisera LinkedIn, mail och video.
Så det är rent konkrast ett nykundsbearbetningsvertyg i Outreach-follan om man säger så.
Det har inte alltid varit det, det är därför det är lite svårare för folk att ha koll på vem nu för att vem grundades jag mig för snart 4,5 år sedan, som bara ett videovertyg.
Så vi var ju i början en video-meddelande tjänst för att enkelt sälja med video, presentera med video, spara tid med video och skicka video-meddelen via mail och LinkedIn.
Men det har ju med tiden, inte liksom en 100 grader pivot men jag brukar säga en 70 grader pivot och växte in till det nya helhetscellvertyget för nykundsbearbetning.
Men det är därför jag fortfarande får höra från vissa så här, vän var vi, men det är inte riktigt, jag förstår inte riktigt nu det nya, det är därifrån det ofta kommer för att vi har liksom gjort den här resan och eftersom en del av nya vän, selva till vän, är hel och halva automatiskt på LinkedIn.
Att jobba med hel automatiskt på LinkedIn, det är i gråzonen med LinkedIn-användande policyn.
Så vi har tagit ett strategiskt beslut att vi kommer inte prata detaljer om den delen av vän på LinkedIn.
Så det är också därför, det är därför också det blir, det är därför också det blir att när folk frågar om vi tror inte på 100% automation Josef, jag tror inte vän är något för oss, då har ju jag alltid svarat redan invändigt till hans.
Jag tror inte heller på 100%, det gör jag inte, jag tror på 80-90% det.
Då säger jag, i dina flöden här vän kan du på ett knapptryck ha halva automatiska to do's.
Så det är exakt vad du ska göra, du har klara mall, du lägger in en video, men du får skjuta iväg dig själv.
Helt 100% compliant med även LinkedIn's policies.
Om man vill köra på det.
Men vad är det konkret det gör?
Vad är det man, är det liksom du vill targeta ett visst antal människor, leta den upp inom de här rolderna och så har man...
Om vi ska ta jätte konkret och inte bara få fler varmeleds, det automatiserar LinkedIn e-mail, det är att du har koll på din målgrupp.
Du vet att jag borde höra av mig till marknadschefer i västra Götaland som jobbar i de här industrierna.
Då kan du antingen kanske du har en lista sen tidigare som du laddar upp i WAN-plattformen och WAN börjar agera med mail, med videos eller LinkedIn eller ger dig telefon till djurs.
Eller så kanske du använder LinkedIn som sök och där söker i Sales Navigator eller i sökfältet, den sökning vi gjorde.
Sen kan du på två sekunder klicka i klick, sätta igång en roll sekvens och sedan börja VAM köra enligt det schemat du har bestämt i VAM med något mail här.
Om de inte svarar så går det vidare till LinkedIn, om de inte svarar där så kommer SMS-et, om de inte svarar där så kanske du ska ringa.
Det vill säga att du kan skala dig själv, det som en bra B2B-säljare gör eller borde göra idag i nykundsbearbetning.
Det vill säga man puffar lite här, man mailar där, man ringer, man borde jobba med video.
Det har vi automatiserat på ett jätte enkelanvärnigt sätt, tydligt att bara följa schemat eller det körs automatiskt.
Och för lite mer, om det är någon som lyssnar på det här, nog sitter på ett drivet säljteam eller vd som jobbar B2B och har CRM och är lite mer avancerad i det som inte är jättetidigt.
Ja, vi har full interaktion med fler CRM, så liksom datan från LinkedIn och vad vi har gjort kan komma insömlöst i CRM-et, så att man får fulla övrigt och spara tid på det sättet.
Det är det lite tidigare nu.
Ja, men nu fattar jag och nu får man ju på något sätt hålla två tankar i huvudet samtidigt här.
Jag är ju en av dem som hatar alla människor som hör av sig till mig, som ska sälja in olika saker, så som ganska många människor gör på LinkedIn, de tycker inte om sånt där.
Men det är ju samtidigt så att om du är säljare så ska du ju höra av dig till folk och du ska höras och du ska synas och då är det givetvis så att det måste finnas system för att synas och då finns det bra system och dåliga system.
Och jag köper liksom varför en säljare vill ha den här tjänsten.
Jag fattar den tjänsten även om jag inte vill bli kopplad, man kan ju skilja på de två.
Men jag tänker att det finns ju en risk i att människor låter väldigt automatiska och inte personliga och jag gissar att det är en sån här invändning som du får ibland, att det känns lite automatiskt eller att det känns inte personligt.
Hur gör man så att ett sånt säljjobb blir personligt mot entreprenören som du söker eller marknadschefen eller liknande?
Vad gör folk för fel för att inte vara personliga?
Någonstans så börjar det ju alltid med, jag är den första som säger att jag är jätte anti-spam, jag är jätte anti-connectad med Johan på LinkedIn, poff, pitch-lappen, tusen tecken, i nylet avskyr sånt, big no no no.
Utan den metodiken jag lär ut är att vi jobbar multi-kanal, vi jobbar med lite LinkedIn här, man ska också jobba med social selling, ge värde först.
Så man jobbar med LinkedIn, ge värde, du är jättebra på det, det var ju därför jag tackade dig här, jag tycker du kör några riktiga banger i reg och bara får tank istället.
Så man ska jobba multi-channel, mixa olika kanaler, var jättetydlig med din målgrupp, du måste veta din ICP.
För annars blir det direkt spärma också, om du skickar och försöker pitcha till någon som uppenbarligen är fel typ av målgrupp, totalt ointressant.
Big no no no också.
Vi har latt in spärrar i värme så du kan bara maila x antal automatiskt per dag och LinkedIn per dag just för att det ska vara det mänskliga, mänskligt beteende, du kan inte, om du vill ha ett verktyg du som lyssnar på här.
Det där är ett ju spännande, mixar LinkedIn med video med mail på ett automatiskt, poff!
Nej du kan inte skicka till 1000 pers på en dag, utan vi pratar att du kan bearbeta x antal hundratals, kring 800 som mest per månad max.
Men vi pratar ett antal tiotals personer mest som dag, för det är en aspekt av det.
Och också så lär jag allt ut att vi får inte vara för aggressivt.
Alltså vissa får för sig att nu har man hittat ett verktyg, nu ska vi poff peppra till Joel-mejlet, har du inte svarat så kommer du på LinkedIn en dag senare, hej såg du mitt mail.
Det är ingen vettig person som fattar någonting om hur beslutsfattare agerar, som tror att du skulle hinna ta action på det inom några dagar, typ en vecka.
Det är liksom alldeles för aggressivt.
Så jag är starkt emot spam på det sättet, utan det måste vara du vet vilka du hör av dig till.
Du har också en bra produkt.
För jag brukar skämtsamt säga att med video och med rätt typ av mässing så blir det bättre.
Du kommer att konvertera med det.
Det finns jättemycket data som bekräftar att du kan få bara ha personeriserat video mellan 26-215% ökad svarseffektens.
26% om det är typ internationellt och mer uppemot hundratalet om det är lokalt på samma språk.
Men om du fortfarande försöker sälja skit, fint paketerat, det kommer fortfarande vara skit.
Så det är därför att du måste veta din ICP, du måste ha en tjänsterprodukt som är bra.
Där kan VAM hjälpa dig att på ett strukturerat tidsbesparens sätt hel och halva automatiskt.
En viktig del här Joel är att bara ha video som är en screenshot från din LinkedIn, du ser dig själv.
Det är inte lika spämigt för att ingen jobbar med video.
Och också om du får en pitch av någon, hur det funkar i Outreach är ju, för första måste ju något i rubriksättningen, det vet ju du med email-kampanjen, något i rubriksättningen eller avsändaren måste ju locka.
Känt brand eller bra rubriksättning.
Det är ju första klicket.
Om du ens, att du ens ska överväget ha ett möte med någon när det är kallt eller svaggummet, det är ju så otroligt dumt att folk fortfarande tror att de säljer att jag kan höra av mig till någon kallt, jag kan ha en ganska dålig pitch.
Och sen kan jag fråga, hej Joel, vill du ta ett 45 minuters möte med mig?
Det är så otroligt dålig köpupplevelse.
Så jag förstår inte.
Istället, om du istället har mjukat upp Joel lite så, du har sett mitt content någonstans och jag har sett att du har droppat en like på mitt inlägg så att där kan prickskjuta in i VAM som man kan på jättestänt enkelt sett.
Och så kommer mailet lite efter det.
Så du känner igen namnet Josef Hallersen eller säljans namn eller brandet.
Och istället för att säga låt oss ta ett möte så har du en trevlig pitch.
Du är alltid fokuserad på något värdgivande och tankeställare.
Och sen skicka med, jag passar på att skicka med en kort video.
Kan jag låna dig två minuter?
Den handlar om det här så du också förklarar kort vad du kommer att se.
Vem skulle kunna hjälpa dig att få fler varmlis genom mixar här?
Skulle du säga att istället för att jag pushar dig och tackar till ett 45 minuters möte, visst är du mer sannolik, om vi har gjort alla steg innan rätt, och budskapet är bra, att investera två minuter i en kort video kontra 45 minuter möte?
Och tror du att du är mer benägen att ta ett möte om du såg en trevlig person som verkar prata om problem du kan relatera till och visa en lösning på dina problem?
Nej men jag bara menar att vi gör ju egentligen samma sak åt det privata hållet.
Det är ju som du sa när jag bjöd in dig till den här podden.
Det är ju för att jag har sett dig i mitt flöde och så har du likat något inlägg då det är såhär.
Fan jag känner igen det där namnet.
Vänta, jag ger det här en vecka.
Och ifall han likar en gång till, då går jag in på hans profil och likar hans inlägg.
Så han vet att jag finns där och lurkar.
Och sen hör jag av mig och säger ska du inte vara med i podden?
Det blir ju, man automatiserar ju den delen av beteendet såklart.
Så jag fattar sen.
Jag tror jättemycket på 50-90% automatisk.
Skala dig själv.
Det är själv med teknik och AI som superkrafter.
Men inte att du bygger bort dig själv.
Vi är inte där än, vi kommer inte vara där på flera år.
Det blir inte bra, det blir stoltigt.
Jag bara ser fram emot en värld när både mottagare och avsändare är AI.
Så att alla bara sitter och är såhär, ja exakt.
Vi hamnar väl där till slut.
Det kommer.
Och på tal om det, jag måste sätta inspel här.
Jag läste om varför du kör din podd och varför det är bra att höra så synas i den sociala kontexten.
Det är literally viktigt nu för tiden.
För när jag har bollat lite med Chatgypity och bjudit en gäster till min podd, min säljmarknadspodd var Amazing Sades, då har den gett, baserat på den datan, den hittade det här.
Och vissa har varit jättebra förslag.
Det är såhär, ja just det.
Så om du inte hörs och syns på LinkedIn eller har en blogg eller podd, då kommer du att hamna efter ni nästa generationen sökmotorer som kommer vara direkt att man pratar med AI.
Och på det sättet, jag har jättemycket värdigivän kontent utom mig som någon vill snacka pitchande, entreprenörskap, sälj eller då video med sälj.
Då är jag, det finns mycket data som backar upp att jag är en bra source att prata med.
Exakt, jag köper det jättehårt.
Jag kommer missa hela det här, din andra podddelen som jag hade tänkt ta med för att vi hinner inte med det.
Du är lite för trevlig här.
Men det jag vill...
Om du inte har ett hårt stopp så kan vi köra på lite.
Jag kör på, men jag vill också fråga om...
Det jag är lite nyfiken är att nu har du dels suttit på businessborden, du har dels jobbat som investerare och sen så drar du ihop och startar upp vem.
Att starta upp ett bolag, det är givetvis bra att man har erfarenhet och det är bra att man har gjort vissa grejer, men det finns ju också en viss naivitet som kan vara positiv i att starta upp bolag för det kommer vara...
Alltså i början är det ju inte as mycket strategi och coola finansiella magigrejer, utan det är ju typ några år av rätt tråkigt jobb som är rätt nötigt.
Kan du se en nackdel i att du har gjort en del för stora grejer för att sedan starta upp en liten grej och bygga den?
Förstår du vart jag är på väg med frågan?
Har det varit svårt under de här åren för att du liksom...
Fan, jag vill vara tio år längre fram i tiden.
Frågar du eller fiskar du nu efter att man kommer från andra saker som hörs och syns mycket?
Och liksom man kanske har fått mycket endorfinkickar, har haft mycket öppna dörrar.
Och så får man börja om med det här tråkiga nösandet som du och jag vet.
Ja, jag fiskar efter exakt det där.
Ja, ja men bra då.
Hur har den känslan varit liksom?
Jag tror att den hade varit brutal om jag inte i unga ålder fått lära mig att hårt jobb är jätteviktigt liksom för ett karaktärsbyggande.
Så jag fick ju som åttaåring med pappa i det städbolaget jag är nu delägare i, jag fick ju följa med och dammsuga som åttaåring.
Jag fick sälja frukt på släktens, på högtorget här, sälja yoghurt och andra frukt som 14-åring.
Jag fick ha mina trappuppgångar städda som 16, 17, 18.
Under gymnasiet gick jag liksom på en håltim och städde och tjänade pengar.
Så jag har liksom haft med mig det.
Så att jobba hårt, det bryr jag mig inte om.
Det rör mig inte alls i ryggmärgen, det liksom är den jag är.
Så där tror jag att jag har haft övertaget.
Annars hade det varit brutalt att det hade varit enkelt att bli citat fat and happy och liksom nej jag tänker inte gå och som vissa kallar jag hundgöra igen och börja om på det sättet.
Men ända, jag lyssnade på Sebastian Simakowski på Breakits tioårsfirande, då intervjuade Stefan honom där.
Och det han sa, jag håller hundra procent med, en av grejerna han sa var att som grundare i tidigt skede så kan du inte tro att du ska jobba dina 30 timmars veckor.
Det behövs tid.
Sedan hur mycket tid, det kan man låta sig vara osäg, men du behöver tiden för att bara gå på dina misstag och fallbegropar inom den branschen, inom den specifika produkten.
Och det enda sättet man kan lära sig det, enligt mig, att bli riktigt framgångsrik, på riktigt som en företagare, är att vara nere i skittegravarna, med kunderna, leverantörerna, partnerserna, felen, buggarna och bara skruva.
Och det har jag fått lära mig, det är en hårdare vän.
Jag har aldrig byggt en tech-produkt förut, men jag är ju en väldigt mycket bättre produktägare nu än jag var startad.
Man var ju naiv.
Jag kanske inte hade startat det om man inte var naiv, men jag tycker fortfarande att jag är naiv.
Om vi ska tappa in på den aviteter, jag tror det behövs för alla entreprenörer.
Jag kom på idén till VAM, när man gjorde sin research och hittade, och det här ska vi köra igång, det är liksom öppet mål just nu i norra Europa och Sverige.
Innan vi hade en klar produkt, men när vi ändå när satt och byggde, då hittade jag, vänta vi är ju inte helt unika, det finns ju några i Amerika som gör varianter av det här ganska bra.
Jag syftar på några som heter Vidyard och några som heter Loom.
De fick jag upp ögonen innan vi hade lanserat, men jag hade ju kommit på idén.
Och det är ganska naivt att tro att det finns några väldigt välfinansierade bolag här.
Ett som hade fått mycket kapital från Silicon Valley, det andra var mer self-funded från Kanada.
Men på den tiden hade de bara någon miljon använder, alltså en-två miljoner, och ändå Series A.
Men att man tänker såhär dit, vi kommer kunna ta in här och köta också på en ny marknad.
Marknaden är stor nog för oss alla.
Det var ju rätt tänkt.
Jag tänkte att det här är inte Winner takes it all, vi tittar på CRM-system, hur många CRM-system finns det inte?
Men att ändå få för sig, de har långt försprång, de har större tid, de vet mer.
Men I got this, nu kör vi.
Denna iliteten är ju ändå så otroligt härlig.
Ja, nej, jag håller med.
Det är fuck it.
Det finns ju någon sån där, nu kommer jag att tog en som drog det i citatet, men att de som är smarta anpassar sig till världen och de som är dumma förändrar världen.
Så alla dumma människor förändrar världen.
Det var just det Jobb som sa.
Det är klart han sa det.
Han sa allt.
The people are crazy enough to believe that they can change the world, other ones actually doing it.
Man måste vara galen på det sättet.
En annan sak som jag är lite nyfiken på samma tema är, kan du uppleva att det är sekt att vara granskad från sidlinjen?
Du har ju ganska fina investerare och fick ju ganska tidigt lite press om detta och du får vara med en del på ställen och snacka om det.
Men än så länge så är det ju ett, och missförstå mig rätt, men det är ett litet bolag än så länge.
Ja ja, 100%.
Kan du känna en press utifrån att du behöver liksom lyckas med detta?
Inte utifrån, nej.
Jag fattar att du känner en press, såklart.
Nej, men utifrån, för mig själv, för jag har ju puttat in mycket pengar själv i varje runda, det tycker jag om man i grunden har ett simpelt knep för att visa att du har skin and gain för sin investerare och när man ska ta pengar, gå in med pengar själv.
Köp in på den värderingen du säger att det är värt, annars är det jättekonstigt i min värld.
Så jag har ju puttat in i varje runda köp på.
Så jag har mycket skin and gain med VAM av egna pengar också, förutom allt tidigare lagt ner.
Så nej, jag känner ingen press utifrån, utan jag känner press från mig själv.
Och för de löfte jag gett till dem som faktiskt har gett mig pengar, trott på mig.
Att folk ska tjäna pengar på VAM och mig.
Sen att det ska bli någon form av crazy unicorn, hundra eller tusen ex, det har liksom släppts nu.
Och jag träffade en av mina investerare bara för några dagar sen och sa, du vet ju liksom var det barkar nu, att ni kommer tjäna pengar på VAM, det är bortomställt väldigt mycket rimligt givet, men att det kommer bli en 200 ex eller 100 ex är fel, det ska du nog glömma.
Och säga, ja, det ni gör nu är jättespännande och all respekt till det, de flesta bolag konka ändå i tech.
Så nej, jag har ingen extern press, jag har mycket press på mig själv och det att jag vill att folk som har trott på mig inte ska bränna pengar in i själ, liksom hålla och köra änden i kaklet.
Och det är aldrig någon som gått så bra som det är nu.
Men jag förstår vad de menar utifrån.
Jag lägger inte in värderingar i vad andra tycker ska säga.
Att i dagsläget i den hårda, men vi har nu att bara bygga ett fint välmående bolag som blir bättre och bättre.
Och jag har inte någon stress.
Jag är fyra år in på resan.
De flesta tror att det ska vara en quick fix på två år.
Det händer ju inte, det vet ju du också.
Man måste ge det fem, åtta, tio, femton år för att bygga något fantastiskt oftast.
Så nej, jag vet att för mig känns det fortfarande som vi nyligen har börjat med det rätta.
Utifrån, om man tittar på alla bolag, inte jättehög omsättning än, förlusten har minskat för varje år och fingers crossed, det är ju mer SaaS-bolag, mer liksom periodiserade, svarta siffror, kassaflöde på titilitet.
Så det går i ett helt rätt håll.
And if you're still standing, det är ju inte över, först är det över.
Så länge inte bolaget har konkat och det går bättre någonsin, då kan folk tycka vad man vill för det är alltid skrattar bäst som skrattar sist, när det värre klart.
Fan, jag tycker vi ska avsluta där, Josef.
Det är en jävligt bra avslutningsmening, så att fact is shit.
Jag är grovt tacksam för att du var med i podden.
Du är ju en energi-
och glädjespridare, tycker jag.
Det bara osar.
Jag är ju på andra sidan, så vi kanske levlar ut till detta avsnittet, blir ungefär 50 procent energi.
Så folk får ta med sig det.
Tack så jättemycket för att du var med.
Vilken rolig historia eller spännande liv du har haft.
Tack.
Tack för att du ville ha mig här.
Det enda sättet man kan lära sig det inrikt mig och bli riktigt framgångsrik på riktigt som en företag är att vara nere i skittegravarna med kunderna, leverantörerna, partnerserna, felen, buggarna och bara skriva...